منذ عام
1986 يصدر مؤشر بيج ماك مرتين في السنه
شطيره ماكدونالدز الشهيره تستخدم كوحده
قياس مبسطه ويعتمد المؤشر على حساب سعرها
في كل دوله بعملتها المحليه ويرصد ما اذا
كانت العمله مقيمه بشكل عادل او مبالغ فيه
امام الدولار بحكم ان بيغ ماك شطيره
عالميه تضم نفس المكونات فمن المفترض ان
تكون التكلفه واحده او قريبه نسبيا لكن
التفاوتات الكبيره في السعر تعكس القوه
الشرائيه لكل عمله في سويسرا مثلا يبلغ
سعر بيج ماكس 6 دولارات و70 سنتا وهو
الاغلى في العالم بينما يقل سعره عن
دولارين في مصر ما يعني ان الجنيه المصري
مقيم باقل من قيمته الحقيقيه باكثر من 65%
طبقا للمؤشر لكن عوامل اخرى تتداخل في
الاسعار بين دوله واخرى مثل معدلات
الضرائب وهياكل الاجور وما اذا كانت
المكونات بحاجه الى الاستيراد وغيرها هي
ليست طريقه دقيقه بالطبع لقياس قيمه
العمله بل مجرد اداه لفهم نظريه الصرف
بشكل اكبر مع ذلك اصبح المؤشر معيارا
عالميا ومدرجا في العديد من المناهج
الاقتصاديه